Hansel was a guy who ordinarily in a
philosophy class you would encounter by
reading a different form the pro slow
jam and there he gives you this really
interesting argument for God's existence
called the ontological argument in
general but we're not going to look at
that instead we're looking at this
dialogue on truth we're dancin was
talking with one of his students and
I'll tell you a little bit about you
know who those people might have been in
a second so why are we looking at this
particular diet well this ties in with
what we call pistol mala G the
epistemology is the part of philosophy
that looks at what is knowledge and what
is certainty what can we actually know
but it's also concerned with truth what
is truth is up and that's one of those
sort of questions that we normally don't
think about because we're so used to
thinking and you know in terms of true
and false and we don't have a problem
with that but when we give to difficult
situations or when we start like digging
into the foundation what is it for
something to actually be true then we
start to get all confused our head start
to spin we feel ourselves a kind of a
loss remember how when we were talking
about Socrates way late earlier in the
semester and Socrates is kind of like a
stingray he asked these people questions
they think they know about things and
then you know point arrives where
suddenly they're like I don't know won't
talk about right that's the way we are
with some things like truth there's
other issues that come up like that too
Augustine talks about this in another
work that I didn't have you guys read
the confessions were recessed well what
is time he says well so long as nobody
asked me that question I think I know
exactly what it is if you put me on the
spot imagine liking to get on the
midterm
asked you just an open-ended question
noticed I'm explain it to me how would
you have done how'd it bad why 242 the
concept to fully understand now that's
an interesting thing to say to for
another concept to fully understand but
it's not a foreign concept right you're
living in time all the time use the word
time twice in a sentence you understood
what I met with that sentence but then
when we want to like look at the thing
itself it does become kind of foreign to
us where it's sort of like with people
right you think you know somebody and
then they do something really wild out
of the ordinary life who is this you
start asking them about their motivation
and then you find out there in a cold or
you know they've got some other weird
you know totally blocked you know off
the the wall leave system you're like
man that's very different than I
expected it to be or even say because
you probably get a very generalized yeah
if you have to have a very generalized
answer no you know think about the
question what is what is truth you know
and this is a question that we're posed
with over and over again in our life
it's one that shows up in literature to
you know and one of the sort of central
points of the gospel narrative think
about one of the characters who have the
power of life and death and basically
one of the few things that the guy
actually says is he asked the question
what is truth doesn't get any answer
that he orders the executions pilot
pilot actually has what is truth because
he doesn't know so you know this is a
pretty deep question and we're going to
explore it through this dialogue the
ants Alma's going to start out with the
the understanding of truth that were
probably the most familiar with that's
probably good ideas start with what you
actually know and then move
to deeper more tangled subjects on the
way and he's doing this in a dialogue
forum why do you think he's doing in the
dialogue because he liked writing
dialogues you might've why do you think
he's yeah leave room for argument or
interpretation okay yeah like with
Plato's hands home is not actually going
to provide you with the full account of
things you have to kind of not only read
between the lines but beyond the lines
and think about how you would actually
apply some of this stuff to through
other circumstances to your own life for
example if you do that a lot of this
will make more sense to you I can tell
you myself I've been reading this
dialogue and rereading it it's a very
short simple dialogue but I've been
reading and rereading it in line
Anselm's of the works for at least now
15 years and I'm still like you know
seeing things in it that I didn't grasp
the time before that so you know put
your own work into the sort of that
perspective you don't have to fully
understand the nature of truth after you
get to the end of this dialogue but you
should be a little bit better equipped
to try to figure these things out so let
me sort of break down to me what he's
going to do in this dialogue and then
we'll go into so the first thing I
excuse try to figure out what are the
different kinds of truth right it will
sort of list those in a second what else
is he doing in here what are the tops
topics is he bringing up well he goes
into this digression looks like a
digression about how something could be
both good and bad at the same time did
you guys catch that you know an action
can be both a right action and a wrong
action
same time that's an important point
that's something that we want to look at
kind of closely because I think that's
going to be very useful for you a lot of
times people want you to see things at a
very on black and white kind of way
something is either completely true or
completely false one of the things that
philosophy equips you to do well this is
why people hootie-hoo do philosophy for
a profession tend to do well on things
like the LSAT and the GRE because it
trains you to make distinctions it
trains you to look at things and say
well in this sense it's true in this
sense it's false or in this sense it's
right in the sense it's wrong so that's
something we want to look at another
thing that he talks about in there which
probably you know hard to wrap your head
around is how God fits into this that
make when you read through that did that
make perfect sense to you you know the
Supreme Truth and how everything else is
inside of the Supreme Truth be able to
wrap your head around that pretty easily
no did it make any sense to any of you
yes no I can understand it didn't he's
working with some concepts here that
like you said we started with familiar
things and they turn out to be very
unfamiliar the notion that somehow
everything would be in God that's kind
of a weird thought so if we have time to
explore that the other thing that he
talks about that's particularly
interesting is you know type of truth
that's in the will that we call justice
what is justice same sort of thing
asking what is truth we think we know
what justice is until we start talking
about Plato wrote a whole book basically
devoted in this question what is justice
knows about that thick because it's a
complicated issue the anthem is going to
try to deal with it
terms of our will what is it we choose
to do what commitments that we make the
way orient ourselves to basic goods and
we'll try to look at a bit of his theory
we won't probably get through all of it
we'll look at that so really we have
four different things to targets we're
going to spend the most time on this you
know what are the different kinds of
truth so let's let's think about what
were the kinds of truth that he talked
about there there are truths in
something or truth of something what was
the first one time anyone remember when
you say let me put it to you this way
when you say something is true what do
you mean by that yeah it's factual
evidence okay now what are you actually
saying is true that case the evidence is
one thing that's the reality of
recurrent state very good so stay then
another term that uses is expression
this may include you know words it can
also include things like like science
you know think about your driving along
and you see a road sign and it tells you
how many of you have actually been
driving around and you've gotten off the
wrong exit because the roadside was
confusing almost all of Jersey is
particularly
really yeah that way up to the side
mislead you the sign said something
about where that exit was going to take
you right when actually that exit was
going to take you say in the opposite
direction we're not even on the same
highway you may get to some of these
these complicated interchanges and you
get off on the wrong highway or you know
you're like in a big city and you think
that you're actually getting onto
another interstate and settle that
you're like right in the middle of you
know some part of the city you've got no
idea where you are your GPS generally
stops working at that point you're like
what am I going to do that's because
signs mislead you those signs were
actually according to handsome false you
know we have we have verbal expressions
we have written expressions we have
signs we get you to sign language we do
this sometimes you know the one that I
thought about we're making gestures
would be like wait you know when we're
doing sort of military type things
there's certain hand signals that it
would use we're saying that you know
there's something five yards over there
right that could be true or that could
be false depending on whether something
really is five yards over there or not
or it could be that person's
interpretation yeah well it's def
person's interpretation we can say that
interpretation is true or the
interpretation is false depending on
whether it conforms to the reality and
that brings us to the second type of
truth in thought when we talk about
interpretations that's what we mean that
interpretation is something inside your
head right if it's your interpretation
this actually leads us to another one
too he talks about truth
the senses and judgment or opinion if I
think for example that your hat is black
and orange right because I I don't know
does that kind of colorblindness exist
where people mix up blue and orange I
know red green does but I don't know
about what's just a student it does
right good finding if I have that
viewpoint my senses are actually we
would say deceiving anselm says it's not
actually the senses themselves that are
deceiving it's your judgment about them
but we'll get to that in a moment but
that's a different kind of realm of
truth so this stuff I think we're all
kind of familiar with Yan song goes a
little bit further and it talks about
her over here talking about truth being
in the will truth being actions and then
he hasn't said yeah the truth in the
being of things and when we get to if
you've made it through the rest of the
dialogue when you get to that point that
would be the point where if you progress
through everything so far it would be
perfectly fine to get free to say what
the hell is he talking about their
lesson I mean if you figured out what
truth in action will is you've done a
good job reading through this dialogue
because that's kind of a tricky idea
truth in the being of things that gets
even more mysterious so let's look at
each of these in turn let's start with
what the most
statements and expressions and one major
way which we say that something is true
is when the statement advancement says
what is yes what is that well this is an
iphone I've just made a statement hunter
right it's either true or false this
could be an empty box you don't know you
see me like tinkering around with it
earlier today and you know we've got
some the habits of assuming that people
don't just carry around cell phone cases
with no cell phones inside right so
you're pretty confident that there's a
cell phone inside here and then it's an
iphone right not what would be some
other possibilities not an adroid or
something like that because I you know
this has got the right shape if I eat
this chalk what will happen to me yeah
I'm probably good sick it depends on if
I chew it or just swallow it right away
if I don't you don't shoo it that's
probably worse for me than shooting it I
don't imagine that heating truck by
itself is good for you that's a
statement what's a statement about you
know something that would happen there
are 24 students in this class I think
now we're missing a few people so that's
a false statement then right that's just
saying something is but that's not
really the case another way to look at
this is thinking about it this way the
statement should be in correspondence
with the reality so if I say I am NOT 19
years old that's a true statement isn't
it
all do you think I am what could you it
was very good guys remember I almost
brought it up before it's kind of weird
because after you get to before you stop
paying attention to suppose it doesn't
matter you know you're over 40 so you
know by the time you reach that point
and that I really issue I'm not 19 I was
19 at one time that was a true statement
that's a 42-21 23 years that was a true
statement 23 years ago it was true for a
period of how long a 11 year at 12
months with 365 days if it wasn't a lead
be right I don't know now what was or
wasn't the leap year suppose we want to
be really technical astronomically 365
days and so many minutes or something
like that right it's only true when the
statement actually corresponds with
reality now that doesn't mean that we
necessarily know every case whether the
state that's true but this is just
saying what it would mean for a
statement to be true in a certain sense
here's where it takes a weird turn
aunt's home says that the statement is
true in another way so let's actually
look at and what he's saying about this
or what he has his student say with him
so his student says
there we go this is a chapter to show me
how I can answer someone should say that
even when a statement signifies that
which is not is so when it's a false
statement it signifies what it should
the end zone has got this idea about
things doing what they want to do when a
statement actually corresponds to
reality and you're saying that statement
is doing what it's designed to do right
so chalk is on the on the desk those
words are designed to signify that chart
the sign that told you turn off at this
this exit here it's telling you to do
something it was designed for a certain
purpose right how do you know what these
things are designed to do what you got
to know the language or the system of
communication that you're working with
so if I were to say you know femdom bush
I'm going to know what that means
literally what is it figuratively means
yeah shut up that's what I heard a lot i
was a kid from my uncle's of my mom
because everybody spoke French usually
thought we kids that know it they were
saying unless they want to tell us to do
something
do that now if you don't know that
language it's just sort of meaningless
words right and we can say the same
thing about other things might say me
how what is that what does that mean no
no because you guys have seen the
cartoon right yeah okay loud what does
it mean doesn't mean goodbye cool stuff
hello yeah and sort of greeting and
stuff like that now you understand what
those words mean in part because we know
that little bit of the language right
here's your's one good thing to know
about languages too if you're going
anywhere and you don't know the language
the first thing that you ought to learn
is the expression I don't know this
microfiche right all right only know a
little bit of this language so that
people will actually not try to
communicate with you in that language
because you won't you won't be able to
tell whether statements are actually
conforming to reality because you have
no idea what's actually being set now
that's a deeper level of truth that's
involved there handsome says or yes it
is a his student saying show me how I
can answer if someone should say even
when a statement signifies that that
which is which is not yes it signifies
what should statement is signifying the
way it ought to he seems to take
signifying to apply equally to what is
and what is not even when it signifies
that what is not is it signifies what it
want to there's a sort of plot a ship
built into language itself so I said the
teacher them who's an some says it's not
customary to say that it's true when it
signifies that which is not is still it
has truth and rectitude brightness in so
far as it'll fizzle well formed sentence
when it says that what it is what is is
it doubly does wouldn't want to since it
signifies both what it undertakes to
signify and is a well formed sentence so
there's two kinds of truth two
statements or expressions words signs
english there is the truth and
expression there's the truth of the
expression yes the s communications and
normally don't even call this meaning
something has a particular meaning a
sentence has a meaning and you can
understand what that sentence means
whether it applies to anything real or
now well let me give you an example of
one that doesn't apply to anything real
what are some of those ways that you
guys used to play with the corresponding
to cartoons like a transformers so that
one I don't know quite so well but
there's an Optimus Prime guy right and
then there's Megatron these are the big
bad guys in a fair fight Optimus Prime
to take Megatron imaginary objects right
there that's never going to correspond
it even if like you're a little kid
you've got your mega tribe you've got
your Optimus Prime and you're having
Optimus Prime beat it mob or something
like that you're just representing
something there's no actual Optimus
Prime out there right hopefully they're
never will going on those movies because
those things are often struck and you
know the good robots don't seem to be
particularly good Hannibal s all of the
stuff that we've been doing all this
this verbal communication has had
meanings those meetings are doing what
they want to do so truth is when a
statement does what it ought to do now
on that basis it's able to have true
expression
you two actually sick of something which
is connected with hopefully some kind of
reality that's actually up there let's
take for example down I say there is no
such thing as Megatron and Optimus Prime
there are no animate sentient robots
that go around beating each other up
fighting you know the middle of cities
or stuff like that that's a statement it
has a meaning right you all understood
the meaning even if you're not into the
Transformers now we can also consider it
in terms of whether that describes the
way reality is does that describe a
reality is your experience and you met
Optimus Prime and Megatron do you ever
plan to do you think that's going to
happen anything is possible okay well
maybe we should say although it's
possible that Megatron and Optimus Prime
exist they currently currently don't
insist right that's going to different
kind of truth than the truth that's
involved in the meaning in both of these
cases the statement is doing what it
wants to do there's a kind of rightness
involved in the truth and these two
different kinds of truth this is the
rightness of the statement doing what it
was designed to signify some things that
actually are the case or to say that
what isn't the case isn't the case you
know and then there is the statement
doing what it ought to do as a state as
language they ask something that you can
understand do you guys see the
difference between this is like one of
the key fundamental ideas behind an
songs theory of truth you see the
difference between these yeah so is the
double meaning of truth of expression
mostly in regards to like if someone is
saying that is the best and you know
there is the best there that is reality
the same is true but that's gotta hold
these kinds of truth all right so say
once again we go back to the foreign
language makes ounces that is a desk in
different language you don't understand
that language does that make to you this
statement it's not as true because a
good question ansel doesn't worry about
that sort of thing it helps that he's
right yuge writing a timer laughs is
almost a universal language you know I
mean I some people have other
vernaculars but that was
language that you're using all across
Europe to signify things what he
handsome would you have to say would be
something like this the statement has
its truth as an expression but you're
just not able to grasp that particular
truth I mean think about this though
here's a problem that could come up with
this what do you make up a language you
don't like twins make up languages every
once in a while the real real close
weird you know sort of anything you mean
anything languages the answer let's say
well once they've actually like set the
vocabulary and the rules that kind of
truth exists and now it can be used to
signify things like dan is coming up the
stairs put away the that we're going to
keep from them whatever twins do I don't
know mostly movies about this sort of
thing those are probably not you know
based in reality earth any other
somebody else have any end up about well
let's go on so we've got two different
closely connected kinds of truth that
are easy to mix up with each other but
we do want to keep distinct they both
you have to do with the language doing
what it want to do but in different ways
this one is in a certain way more
fundamental this always exists so long
as you have the language or the signs or
the communication going on this always
exists this only is true when things
actually are the case so the statements
my cat is 30 years old that's an
understandable intelligible statement
that has truth the language is doing
what it ought to do it's never going to
be true this calf don't live that maybe
some cat somewhere he has but generally
right they don't live that long I never
had a cat that in 30 years so that's a
false expression what would make it true
me if there actually was a cat that was
my cat that lived that long once we've
got this in place now you can go through
the rest of the dialogue and make sense
of all these are the kinds of truth
these types so let's think about a
thought now we're not looking at
expression looking at thought what do we
use a lot to do yeah I mean it's a
little loosey-goosey when it comes to
this you know he probably should have
been a little bit more clear and saying
wailing to their slot like reasoning
things out and you know figuring things
about what we ought to do and making you
know good cases for things and then
there's thought just like just thinking
about it like and I thought before I got
in the room I thought I wonder how many
students are going to be here you know
break just finished are all look it's
eight o'clock class or all of these
these guys going to be here well they're
gonna want to get their midterms back so
yeah they're probably an all mixture of
the year sure enough look you guys are
all here right sup or two students there
on a count of four I'm surprised because
they're good students I'm thinking about
things right my thought can match
reality work in that match reality if I
did say I can imagine myself to be
somebody who I'm not like well I can
imagine myself to be Optimus Prime right
wha grounds are making robot noises and
start looking so you know it's picking
fights with people that I think are
Megatron I'd be crazy and why would I
mccray because my thought but some match
reality now within those with a crazy
world one second within the crazy girl
there is still age
the thought you know and that's kind of
a coherent thought the trouble is that
it doesn't matter map onto reality right
yeah great but would it be your reality
society well that's the thing about
reality you only get one of them
according to handsome you know it's
what's actually out there and we can
have our pieces of reality but my view
of reality would then be false right
because it doesn't conform to the way
things actually are again like if I have
you know if I think eating chalk is
really good for me like when I was a kid
one of the gross things that some of the
other kids would do we are in this
little Thai schoolhouse and we get to
eat in our desks there are only four
rooms in school house and then bringing
the food from the high school down the
road and I don't know we got this
started but when we did hamburgers or
like you know pizza burgers or things
like that anything they had a bond with
we'd have a little ketchup packets and
stuff like that some of the kids would
redo the desk and they get out of bottle
boners I put that in there another
hamburger yeah they'd say oh yeah this
is really really good taste songs so
good and all that and then you know we
get into taste that's very subjective
you know it's hard to pin down is it
good for you to eat Elmer's glue no yeah
I don't think it's good for you I don't
think it's a healthy choice ok and the
teacher would like try to put you know
put squashes but it's tough to do kids
are squirrelly and they were like you
know 25 of us in the classroom each one
of us had our own desk and some kid do
it real quick now the teacher can say to
the kid hey what's wrong with you and
the kid can say I think this is really
good for me this is like my health food
regimen well that kid would have a
thought which doesn't actually conform
to real it doesn't matter that the kid
thinks that he's right that's part of
why it's a false lot because kid
guy Ron use a difference here between
these kind of things so truth and
thought is a lot like truth in
significations when it come to the
senses it's a little bit more
complicated and this is where I give
smash in the race reality is they're
going to you today motor assesses good
package what's up they guide us in a way
WaterSense is actually deliver to us
there is something that the medieval is
already what is your eyeball delivering
to you right now to information so
reality senses you know there's some a
back-and-forth k there is process of
getting information oftentimes we call
this sense data or perceptual data what
do your eyes you actually get to you
before your brain puts it together like
like patterns of like actually
electrical impulses handsome doesn't
know that because he doesn't know that
much about the workings of the brain or
anything like that but he thinks that
there's like data that's coming it's
like basically coming through the eyes
sound you know we're hearing things
again he didn't know it was sound waves
but you could make his theory fitness
smell you know taste we have we have
certain receptors that are taking things
in touch you know now can your senses be
deceived your senses are to see every
single day because every single one of
you looks at a phone or a computer or at
a TV screen and when you do that you are
deliberately allowing your senses to be
deceived so that you can get some
information like if you have something
come up out here that looks like a
scroll it's not a scroll right it's not
made of paper why do people like the
Kindles because it looks kind of a
little bit more like reading paper
that's deceiving all those you know
people doing things on TV not only are
they usually doing things that aren't
true even the reality shows are pretty
scripted right but those people aren't
there in that box and we all know this
right we're used to we're used to
processes of deceiving our senses and
the medieval Z to do about this they had
plays they had paintings you know they
knew that a painting is not the actual
thing he's got this example about a kid
who sees a sculpture of a dragon and
then freaks out why is it kid freaked
out because these are just the external
senses and then there is the inner sense
remember we encountered this with blog
esteem and the inner sense takes in what
the external senses are giving it and it
processes that information and it puts
it together in objects and then the
inter sense does the guide that you were
talking about the intercept says hey
watch out there's a dragon but there's
no dragon there's just a stone statue
right or the inner sense is what tells
you hey will you put that stick in the
water the stick actually bends you guys
both on that trick right does it stick
actually bad no and you know why your
external senses they're not actually
lying to you they're doing their best
all they can do is provide you with the
information then yeah it looks best to
me your eyeballs would say but your
inner sense is where what add some calls
opinion or judgment take place and they
asked is actually about reality if you
see whatever we don't see dragons
about them what are some of the things
that we owe you watch a horror movie
right you watch your movie by yourself
on a saturday night in your dorm room
all by yourself we're in the house when
all your roommates are gone where's your
into parents house and they're all gone
and you stay up real late and you watch
a scary scary or not you know just a
schlocky 11 work you're watching it
you're like man this could this could
actually happen you know or know this
probably isn't going to happen but but I
don't know now suddenly you're annoys
now what's your reaction your head darts
over to this okay dirt what do you feel
no crap is happening what's that oh crap
it's happening yeah you not only feel
fear which which is understand that's an
emotion that's also coming you know from
the inferences of their being drawn you
actually have an idea like it's that guy
from the movie or it's something worse
you know the ones that I always found
the scariest you know adaptations of
Japanese movies because they tend to be
very media conscious like the garage you
know where she can actually come through
the screen or the ring where she you
know again the scary girl comes through
the screen because when you're watching
anything hey wait a second I'm watching
a screen right there right what's going
on their part of is a process of thought
part is just your inner sense and it's
making judgments about reality is there
any little ring girl who's going to come
out of the TV and get you I hope or yes
that's a good question if it's in terms
of like visual hallucinations or hearing
voices or things like that a
schizophrenic paranoids gets a proud to
through quite different disorders
apparently to be a little bit different
in this case a schizophrenic was hearing
hallucinations or experiencing
hallucinations there's something wrong
with the census in the way that the
interface of the brain the brain is
actually producing is what we think that
is brain is producing SaLuSa Nations how
would he handsome I guess he would have
to say is what the inner senses is
somehow producing these things itself he
didn't have any theory about but that's
over then was now a paranoid person
what's wrong with a paranoid person is
that they think everybody is persecuting
them and that would be a matter thought
not so much a matter of the inner sense
that's actually having thoughts about
things like that that you know that guy
over there he's looking at me funny he
doesn't like me I better watch out for
him there's a whole train of thought
that's going on and those thoughts are
coherence as part of the problem
comparative turn right so they're like
totally coherent but they don't
correspond reality if you don't you
don't just like me right you know they
can't be funny better there we go see
even if you didn't like me one day you
know looking at me funny
trying to kill me and shove me in a
closet or something like that right
there we go so that would be a problem
with untrue thoughts but yeah this is a
good question Hansol Hansol doesn't
sketch these things out as well as he
could let's go on since we're getting a
little bit short on time let's going to
talk about will and the action so it's
easy to figure out what it means for
things to be true how to do this lot to
do or want to be in certain way or
rightness when it comes to statements or
thoughts or things like that the
whittles about choices choices and
commitments it's the faculty that makes
you along with reason distinctively you
you have a free will you can choose to
do things that are right you can choose
to do things that are wrong right we've
all experienced them and some would say
that as the will is making these kinds
of decisions the will is choosing
matrixes rightly the right thing you
mean
a lot to do and in other cases is doing
is willing long the wrong so for example
what's something you don't like people
doing that you consider to be a wrong
act that sometimes you have to suffer
around that okay stealing yeah we say
you should respect other people's
property right the opposite of theft
would not just be like keeping your
hands off if you like saying yeah other
people's stuff as other people's stuff I
ought to respect them so you could have
two different orientations you get into
a situation of temptation will be
something that you might be tempted to
steal your item okay I suppose I mean
that seems like you have a big hassle to
me because there's a lot of work that
has to be done to like make an iphone do
things for you other than how many could
just remove the SIM card I guess put a
new sim card n but leave it a little bit
more to it than that anyway so let's say
you see an iphone sitting out and it's
not even like you've decided to actively
steal you're not sneaking in saying this
way it's just sitting out there somebody
left it in the bathroom
all right yeah it's late at night
nobody's around you haven't seen anybody
coming or going for hours you know maybe
your ethical office got some other
crunch you're cleaning up in a
restaurant you're you're working right
do you take the iphone keep it for
yourself even though it's somebody
else's or do you try to find the
rightful to be pretty easy to find the
rightful owner of an iphone if you
wanted to what want you to and some
would say you ought to actually try to
find that floor but you could choose am
going to keep this screw that my iphone
now they're lost my game Finders Keepers
losers weepers as we will save your kids
you guys remember they still say that
okay I taught my daughter that that
everybody was happy because we got from
an aunt Sonia in perspective with a
happy teaching here Finders have a duty
to return property to the rightful
owners that quit is going to Ryan Lizza
so you have a choice and you have a
choice to aneya truth in the will or
falsity when you choose the wrong thing
you're in a certain sense choosing to be
untrue choosing to make falsity exist in
in yourself and some would say you can
talk about a false will not falls in the
sense that it's not actually intending
what it would have intends we're
choosing what the chooses are committing
to what it convinced you but it's
choosing the wrong thing does this sort
of way of talking about things does this
this resonate with you does this make
sense to you know yeah have one quick
question what about like three area
scenario
play sure many times when we were
talking about gray areas we're going to
be really careful buckets many gray
areas aren't really great yours they're
just complex black and white areas where
it gets a bit murkier we'll explore one
of those in a moment the question about
can something be good and dad at the
same time right and wrong at the same
time if it really is a total gray area
that it's in different then then it
could go either way you know if it
doesn't matter in the long run or in
terms of anything else whether you
choose to buy this birthday card that
birthday card the person whose birthday
you're trying to celebrate that you are
willing you know to choose one or the
other but it's not a moral choice it's
not one that would have truth or falsity
and that's yeah well I was going to kind
of brought up in is with the ice yeah if
you took it but then turned it into de
los and activating possession would be
wrong but turning in Lock and pound
right now and some would say the taking
possession by itself is not wrong its
volume taking a possession order to do
you're taking it into possession in
order to keep it for yourself for all
time that's wrong taking it into
possession is two handed and loss and
finally good at that you need something
else private game right and so it's not
that taking somebody else's property
that by itself is the wrong thing motive
comes in so the right thing could be
blossom found now you're getting
somebody's property away that's not good
well yeah the thing is you got to
properly describe the action for Hansel
you're not giving away somebody else's
property that's not the best way to
describe it what you're doing is you're
turning it into lost and foe that's the
best description because Lost and Found
is where we set things that are supposed
to eventually find their way back to the
rightful owner if there's a problem with
the rightful owner knows to go you want
to be really careful about reedus cry
believes that sort of make them suddenly
become go from good to be a door or vice
versa the Anselm estates really
important to find the best description
for any action yeah you know the
intention is this part of what the will
is to your will is what you intend with
you don't just will the action itself
you will the motive by which you're
doing the action and you could have a
disconnect between the action itself and
what you're intending yeah what if
instead of turning the phone into say
lost or found you take the phone and
decide that you can't find the owner so
you get to like charity or something
like that so yeah that could be good to
you know when we give to these sort of
things you'd be more complicated than
just one single option that's being
right so in this regard the falsity or
the wrong truth as well is mostly what
is harmful to others but beneficial to
one that was a good question and someone
is going to only with it up he's going
to pray this in terms of justice let's
go through truth of the action action
also just like will has ought to or
rightness to it and if its action that's
good right it's thereby true if it's
wrong bad so here's where we get to the
question there handsome how do we
evaluate whether naturally is good or
bad true or false a hand this is a
rhetorical yeah we're Devon ants on
evaluates it you can't with some things
look at in terms of that is it
beneficial to you as it beneficial other
people's is harmful to other peoples
hold to you for human beings we go
beyond that let's start at a really
basic level when things do what they
ought to do here's any action for
example and this this eraser is going to
do with it ought to do my whole what
about it to do when I let it go it
oughta fall right does he have any
choice about that that hope not because
we don't think that that has a will and
he sort of Battleship choice your dog
has puppies should your dog take care of
its puppies yes it should take care
should your dough I eat it to us no I
mean unless I don't know maybe one of
the puppies is devil puppy and it's
going to destroy the world or something
like that we can come up with weird
scenario but no in general there's sort
of natural processes that will work the
way that they do those are never going
to do the wrong thing even if they do
things that might harm us he use the
example fire burning right fire ought to
burn that's the nature of fire now if
you put your hand in the fire where the
fire is a forest fire and it gets going
and all around you and burns up your
house and burns you up it is doing
something harmful to to a being but the
fire is not like me I'm going to burn
everybody as bad as I can the Fire
doesn't doesn't do this it just acts it
does what it does we're different we
have wills we have three rooms we can
think about what we're doing and we can
choose to do the actions that we ought
to do or the actions that we want not to
do how do we decide between them
sometimes I like I said it is on the
basis of benefit plan some calls
beneficial goods you know I want to take
care of an old person crossing the
street I'm benefited even if they're
like you know spitting at me and saying
I don't want your help you know or
something like that I'm still doing them
a good turn maybe really what I want to
do if i see that they're likely to get
themselves hit
if I were say this is really know too
much hassle for me I'm going to leave
you on your own I'm going to tell you
your autonomy your dignity to cross the
street by yourself and then bam they get
it by the car and someone would actually
say no I should have done a great thing
which is to to you know put up with
their stuff and help them across the
street in some cases doing things that
seem to be beneficial for people won't
really be beneficial for them our
actions are either good a bit so there
are a lot they're much more like truth
and signification when we use our
faculty and action for the sort of
things that it was intended to do to do
the right thing to do good things to
prevent bad things from happening then
we're using it right the action of the
eraser is much more like you know the
way that truth and signification work
for language itself the words I am
standing here in front of you they don't
choose to be what they are right they
just work the way that they do they
convey information then you can use them
later on for doing true or false things
likewise we can use the entire natural
world for using our own ass again you
know what designs are action we can use
this entire natural world and its
processes for doing what we want so if I
decide to throw a piece of chalk hit
want to do it's not the trucks fault
right let's say silly it pulls your eyes
right terrible sort of thing to think
about but I'm sure somebody's done it on
something for another right so somebody
throws a piece of chalk hits you in the
eye pokes your eye out it's their fault
that's not the chalks fault right the
chalk is is what damage to your eye but
the truck is just obeying natural laws
and it was a human action a human will
that did that and that give any action
wrong or bad or in a certain sense false
because it's going against what block to
be the case now canon the action there's
two of the things when I look at the
body actions notion about justice which
we'll see if we can get to very quickly
yeah can it actually be right or wrong
at the same time this goes to the great
area thing show right the enemy action
the writer on at the same time or in
that way the true or false episode
insult says yes if you think about any
action you have a couple different
things going on you had I the first with
acting agents and that is a technical
term we call the other person the
patient the person who is experiencing
the action and then they're going to be
the means so you know the example I
throw a piece of chalk at you and it
pokes you in the eye and damages your I
talk as the means I'm the actor you're
the patient right that's a wrong action
Danny you deserve to have your eye poked
out by piece of chalk yeah and you feel
that you ever did deserve give your eye
poked out no good so you would be the
wrong person to do that too is there
anybody who may be does deserve to get
their eye poked out with a piece of
chalk maybe there could be somebody like
a person goes around you know poking
other people's eyes out with a piece of
chalk and it's done that said let's say
50 people maybe they do dessert yeah
they would be the right patient right
even if even if you have that person in
front of you are you the person who
ought to be poking their eye out with
Savchuk probably now if we were to say
that there was any person who ought to
be doing that who would it be maybe yeah
a judge who's administering a you know
kind of penalty of you suffer what you
imposed on other people the penalty fits
the crime kind of thing handsome has a
situation like that very much in mind he
talks about beatings right in a meeting
there is a person doing the beating
there's a person suffering the beating
are there cases where a person want to
be beat and some thought there was and
maybe you disagree with this but am some
flood that certain kinds of punishment
could involve beatings I actually have a
paper that I wrote a lot of time ago
which was originally entitled when watch
students beep beep and anthems the
answer is very very infrequently you
know compared to all of his
contemporaries but he did think there
was some legitimate use of corporal
punishment who would be the person who
authorized to do that the person who
actually has that as their job their
role he would probably in today saying
the you know the judge the justice
system that's the person whose
attendance is that not vigilantes going
around and you know fighting crime on
their own or something like that that
would be the right person to do it and
they would be doing it to the the right
person that action would be would be
right across the board some people do
deserve to be cheap let's just say that
you grant that right because an someone
who who do you think deserves in a good
I mean any criminal like think about
somebody really falafel things that you
would like to give a meeting to anybody
come to mind the rest of you go longer
than anybody relies good good thrashing
yeah okay let's let's say we go with
this Liars but that what if it's a white
line yeah that's where we good it forgot
what I had in mind was like picking like
somebody like he's dead John got
John guy deserved a beating or jeffer
down he deserved it could be a sort of
things that he did let's say you know if
we go along its idea that corporal
punishment is deserved anyway think
about somebody who you feel actually
does deserve you if you have anybody now
are you the right person to do that
let's say you come up to the mountain
street that's just you very actually
state the cops are caught them they
bring them into the room and you
actually say just 15 minutes alone with
them like in law and order video
sometimes right and they say okay yeah
that sounds good so you go in and you
say remember me well it's against the
law right but let's say that now the
cops are looking the other way and
nobody's going to punish you for it that
person really does deserve beating but
you're not the right person to get that
feeding the action is right in the sense
that that person does deserve a gaming
but it's wrong from the perspective of
the agent you're not the right person to
be feeding yeah well maybe the duly
appointed authorities or somebody like
that yeah so like just put in like an
some terms like say he was talking with
a student and then student goes off and
talk to someone else he says something
wrong and that personally like oh you
did something wrong because of a beating
and it's in the beating Bowman reality
it should be the teacher since so this
one student is giving another student of
eating something on the landline right
so let me see
I understand so Anson was talking to the
students that's the student hey user
beating that student goes over it tells
another students at the other students
that's fine here you go here's your beer
yeah that would be good yes situation
will like like this the last thing I
want to say is has to do with justice
itself so Anselm is going to define
justice as brightness of will that goes
beyond the rightness of will requires
not only willing the right thing for the
right action making the right choice it
involves willing or the right the motor
so you know for example feeding the
hungry is that something that you think
you ought to do it's a good thing are
there ways in which you can do that but
for the wrong reason you want to feed
the hungry so you can fatten them up so
they'll die down to mobicity later on
that's not a good rhythm right you want
to feed the hungry so that you can feel
like a big impressive person and look
really great you want to feed the hungry
just for the tax write-off or something
like that and some would say that's not
the right motive and so there's
brightness of well he says for his own
safe ultimately what it means to be a
just person what it means to be a good
person is not just that you do the right
thing but that you do it for the right
reason and then when it comes down to
the tempting situations the tough
situations you actually say hey I want
to keep on being a good person and in
order for me to keep rightness will I
have to make the right choice it's
putting things into this kind of
perspective and some things that make
person actually just that you know
represents that goodwill so that's where
we'll leave up and